when I think back to all the biggest  changes that I made or biggest progress  that we've made  it all came from lots of small things so  at one point I remember sending an email  every day to someone who I wanted to  offer me a job and I think about that  that getting the job was a big thing but  it came down to 30 emails and those 30  emails came down to 30 moments and those  30 moments came down to one intention to  want to live my purpose and so you could  say a really big thing happened based on  a ton of really small things and I think  that's what's interesting that it's  always a collection of small things that  lead to a big win as opposed to one  small thing or one big thing